- Good morning, Karen.
Good morning, Angel.
(teenagers talking over each other)
- There's areas of the brain
that track the human face
and other areas that track just eyes,
or track just the voice,
or track the smile,
track the disposition
of your face and body,
so that we're exquisitely attuned to the
attitude of the human being
that you're interacting with.
We know that we start this way.
When you look at the studies
on very young human babies,
even newborns, newborns are
captivated by the human face.
And newborns at birth have the ability
to imitate the facial
postures of another person.
So they open their mouths
when you open your mouth
and they stick out their tongue
when you stick out your tongue.
Eye gaze looks as though it's one
of the most critical features
of our social brains.
Without realizing it,
we do a lot of looking
at what the other person's eyes are doing.
If you look at the kids who are very good
at following the gaze of another person,
their language skills
speed much more quickly
to a higher level than the children
who are not following eye gaze.
So, the ability to track eye gaze
and the tendency to do so
boosts learning tremendously.
So why should teachers care
about this information?
There's a learning opportunity here.
You can create a moment of real synergy
that creates better learning for all,
when children are put
together in small groups
so that they have the opportunity
to track the information
that attracts others.
Building classrooms and
class attitudes that say,
"We're going to do this together.
"We're going to work in pairs or in groups
"and we're going to solve
problems collaboratively,"
means that you're allowing
this face-to-face interaction
to thrive, to let the
brains of the children
implicitly learn from the signals
that are automatically there
when we interact with one another.